how's everybody doing today me I'm a
little sad to be honest in fact I'm
actually very sad because my biggest
inspiration in film criticism
unfortunately today did pass away on the
east coast of the United States as a
rental store called family video and I
was walking through there today and I
got a text it was my friend informed me
that Roger Ebert had passed away now I
don't normally like to make videos about
people who have died and how I feel
about them because I feel like in some
way it might be inappropriate in this
case I strongly disagree because Roger
Ebert is one of the biggest reasons that
I'm talking to you right now and I don't
want to make this video sad I want to
make it a tribute to the many great
things that Roger Ebert has done in the
realm of film criticism to inspire
myself and countless others and I want
to tell you a little bit about my story
so you can get an idea of why this day
really actually hit me a lot harder than
I thought it would if you guys have
followed me for a while you know that my
parents raised me on great films they
showed me Star Wars and The Princess
Bride and back to the future and films
that really inspired me a lot as a kid
and it got me into movies in the sense
that I really enjoyed them but it wasn't
until I was about 14 years old that I
started to see movies as an art form I
started to recognize that there were
people behind the camera that there were
screenwriters and gaffers and directors
and light technicians and you know
production designers and things like
that I had never actually thought of
that in the past I always just viewed
movies as it's a movie but when I was 14
years old I saw a film called signs and
this film really inspired me and it made
me want to explore the realm of
directing and it made me interested in
movies as an art form and I remember I
went home that day and I started
actually looking up reviews for the
movie signs and I had ever done that
before I wanted to know where other
people affected the same way that I was
were other people inspired the same way
that I was were there other people out
there who saw the same film that I saw
and I came across Roger Ebert's review
of science and he gave the film four
stars which is his highest rating and he
went on to talk about M night Shyamalan
s use of suspense and the building of
tension in the film and he likened it to
Hitchcock and that made me start
thinking hey my mom showed me
rear-window when I was younger and I had
seen psycho at that time and I
remembered oh yeah that's right Alfred
Hitchcock is a really good director and
through Ebert and through that film that
I saw I really started to gain a major
appreciation for film and I'll never
ever ever forget that and that's one of
the biggest reasons why I wanted to make
a video to express my love for that man
and what he did for film criticism and
for me and just honestly I don't even
want to say the words film criticism
anymore that man made me appreciate
movies more thank you for doing that mr.
Ebert but as I grew older and into my
teens I started getting really into
short filmmaking and I made quite a bit
of shorts as a teenager and I really got
into the idea of being able to produce
movies and actually somehow affect
someone else's emotions when I realized
that I had the ability to take video and
audio and combine it in a way that
created an emotional response whether it
was laughter or fright or tears or
suspense when I realized that that could
be done through film I suddenly became
extremely engrossed in it and I love the
idea of examining movies and making my
own because I really enjoyed seeing
people's responses and I enjoyed putting
people on some sort of a ride and I made
quite a bit of films as a teenager I did
every single cliche you could think of
the killer outside with the knife the
fight scene that is horribly
choreographed my first few attempts at
dramatic dialogue were just insanely
awful and when I watch them nowadays I
cry with laughter they're just amazing
from that standpoint you know they're
hilarious but they're awful but through
roger ebert's reviews that i continued
to read i grew an appreciation for a
film that i had never had before
another thing that Roger Ebert did for
me was he told me it was okay to not
like a movie that maybe everyone else
likes despite the fact that I personally
strongly disagree with his two-star
review of die hard
I read his review and I can understand
where he was coming from but what that
told me was you don't have to like ever
humongous classic film you don't have to
say oh yes this movie in particular yes
that's a great film because a whole
bunch of other people said it was good
you can form your own opinion and still
make sense of it and that's something
that Roger Ebert taught me that no one
else did because most film reviewers are
afraid to admit that they maybe don't
like a film that is virtually praised
and loved by all
Roger Ebert was not that film critic and
I strongly respected him for that but he
also was not a film critic that was
afraid to give a positive review to a
film that maybe a lot of people are
loathing or that a lot of people are
hating on because one of the biggest
things that Roger Ebert taught me as a
film reviewer was to view a film from
the audience's perspective of what they
would like to see or what they are
anticipating and does the film deliver
on that level or are you sitting there
as a film reviewer expecting it to
please you in every regard or are you
recognizing that not every film is
designed to do that and certain films
have an audience and those audience
members are entitled to want what they
want out of a film to this day that's
why I do go into certain film genres
knowing that this probably isn't going
to be for me but I can at least respect
those who appreciate it because it was
made more for that demographic or that
age group it doesn't mean that I'm going
to go into the Smurfs too later this
year saying oh it's just for kids it was
fine because I saw the Smurfs won and I
yeah I hate that movie I recognize
though that kids under five will
probably really enjoy it and I remember
I even said that in my review as I grew
up I started to watch Roger Ebert's TV
show and at that time it was with
Richard Roeper and I watched his reviews
and then going back and forth and that
gave me the idea of a debate with a
critic of someone who maybe I disagree
with this person I can actually discuss
film with someone getting to know their
opinion without putting them down or
being condescending towards that
individual and I'll never forget there
were times when I was growing up that I
would go to the blockbuster or the
Hollywood video to store chains that
aren't around anymore sadly I missed
those stores and I would look
specifically on the VHS tapes yes the
VHS tapes does it say to thumbs up on
there does it say that Roger Ebert or
Richard rope
Gene Siskel liked this movie they did
okay know what I'm gonna watch it I
don't know what this movie is about but
they liked it I'm gonna watch it that
taught me to accept that other films
that I may not be interested in were
good you know I might not on my own just
choose to watch a certain film but
because he recommended it because I
trusted his opinion I decided to watch
many different genres of film foreign
language subtitled whatever I everything
I wanted to see what it was all about
and through him I learned to appreciate
all different types of film and not just
action or comedy or cartoons you know I
learned that other films were really
good and had something to offer and I
have them to thank for that
eventually he released on his website
links to all of the former episodes with
him and Gene Siskel and I started to
watch those and one of the first ones I
saw and one of their most entertaining
ones still was the review of Jaws the
revenge
it is absolutely hilarious and it was
one of the first times I ever saw a rant
review and if you guys don't know those
are some of the things that I enjoy
doing the most that's kind of become my
specialty or staple is that I do serious
rants because the first two reviews that
got me noticed in anyway on YouTube were
for The Last Airbender and Dragonball
Evolution ah but through Ebert and
Siskel and watching them rant about how
the shark followed the Brody family
around and how this family of sharks is
actually hunting the Brody family and
how hilarious that was to them got me
the idea of you know what I can actually
make a rant video but keep it
light-hearted and funny I don't have to
just sit there and be angry all the time
I could actually make it funny and
comical and I have them to thank for
that as well so despite the fact that I
am sad that mr. Ebert has passed I want
to thank him for the legacy that he
leaves behind for all the things that
he's taught me as a film reviewer and
for the continual inspiration that I
know I will receive from even reading
his past reviews and from seeing the
videos that he did in the past with
Roper and Siskel
I know that I'll continue to be inspired
by that man forever I'm also very
interested in knowing if he had written
any reviews before he passed that aren't
published yet because of some studio
embargo I would
much like to read them I just want to
say again thanks to Roger Ebert because
he really honestly is one of the biggest
reasons that I'm talking to you guys
right now and I hope you enjoyed this
video and I hope they enjoyed this brief
tribute to him I'm going to lay off my
signature catchphrase because I feel
that it's too comical for this video I
just want to tell you guys thanks very
much for watching and I'll see you again
very soon
[Music]